-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight,
and now we're going to
get to the news.
In a new interview,
former vice president Mike Pence
criticized President Biden
and said that he is
"embracing the politics
of the radical left."
Are you kidding me?
If anything, he falls
pretty hard to the right.
[ Laughter ]
In the same interview,
former vice president Mike Pence
said that after
the Capitol attack,
he talked through it
with former president Trump,
and then they
"rolled our sleeves up
and finished working together."
I don't buy it.
The only way Trump ever
rolled his sleeves up
was to sell a fake Rolex.
[ Light laughter ]
Pence also said in the interview
that he will
"always be proud to have served
alongside former
president Trump,"
because in the end,
there is no bond stronger
than Stockholm syndrome.
[ Light laughter ]
President Biden spent the day
yesterday at the beach.
And when there was only one set
of footprints,
that's when Jill carried him.
[ Laughter ]
Former president Trump said
in a new interview
that he has not asked
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
if he is running for president
in 2024
but added that he thinks
he would win over DeSantis.
Well, there's only one way
to find out --
a long, nasty,
drawn-out primary season
where you two guys
are both emotionally
and politically eviscerated,
debating each other's last
brain cell into the ground,
destroying the Republican Party
and everything
you both stand for
until there is only one husk of
a man left standing in the GOP
to actually run
in the election...
Jeb!
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go!
A rare -- a rare
round of applause for Jeb.
American Airlines has announced
that it will no longer
service Toledo, Ohio,
due to a pilot shortage,
despite being the only
commercial carrier
to service the city.
So if you have to go to Toledo,
I have even more bad news.
[ Laughter ]
A man in the U.K.
said in a new interview
that he drank 30 cans of Pepsi
a day for 20 years
but ended his addiction
after doing hypnotherapy.
Man, that guy must have been
hard to hypnotize.
"You're getting very sleepy."
"I'm really not!
I'm really not, though.
I'm wide awake."
That's right --
A man in the U.K.
said that he drank 30 cans
of Pepsi a day for 20 years.
Even crazier, another man in
the U.K. has had RC Cola twice.
[ Light laughter ]
If there's any RC Cola fans
in Toledo watching tonight,
it's a --
Apologies.
Today was actor
Jussie Smollett's 40th birthday.
At least he says it is.
[ Laughter, groaning ]
Move over, RC Cola joke.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to new data,
the price of a pound of lettuce
has increased by more than 11%
in a year.
To give you an idea of what
a pound of lettuce looks like,
order a Big Mac.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody!